m night shyamalan movies i tell you you
know his movies are like a loot box
you know it's i don't know what it is i
don't know what i'm in for his movie
could be something that's amazing it
could be something that sucks
could be surprisingly enjoyable could be
a thing i don't care to experience again
in my life but i'm always interested to
open the box you know i'm like
brad pitt in seven what's in the box
it's the only time i can compare myself
to brad pitt but point is
new shyamalan film let's do it
so old is a movie written and directed
by m night shyamalan i guess it's based
off of a novel or something like that i
know nothing about the novel that it's
based on i guess it's not a direct
translation but
based on so the basic premise pretty
simple there's a family they're on this
vacation they go to this beach and then
other families join them on this beach
and then they realize that
people are getting older very quickly on
this beach enter the shyamalan thrills
and mystery and
sometimes cheesy awkward dialogue that
sticks out but i've always enjoyed this
specific type of execution in the horror
thriller genre you know this
group of people in this one isolated
area
they just can't get out like that movie
the ruins i guess not a lot of people
liked that movie i was a projectionist
at a movie theater at the time i was
like i'm going to watch a scene in the
ruins oh it turned up the volume up in
the projection booth i was like oh it's
at the beginning and i just
ended up watching the ruins and really
enjoyed it haven't seen it since 2008
maybe it sucks i don't know but i i like
that kind of scenario where it's just
like we're isolated bad things are
happening we need to get out of here and
we're just kind of
at the whim of the situation at the whim
of nature at the whim of sped up time
it's just
it's interesting it's like a social
experiment what would this group do
in this intense situation that
simultaneously is changing everyone
around you also making you
come face to face with your mortality
also come face to face with the people
you love around you and their mortality
and what would other people do
if they're around people and suspicions
and that's when the movie's at its
strongest the movie old not the ruins
did i make that transition the bummer is
this movie was executed in a way where
it looks like it was supposed to have a
super vague
year 2000 m night shyamalan trailer kind
of like unbreakable where you could just
have bruce willis sitting down hearing
that he survived a train wreck and
that's that because you're gonna watch
the movie because you saw the sixth
sense
in the way the slow reveal of hey there
are rusted things on the beach and when
some people are looking a little older
to the way the camera is kind of
blurring out the faces of the kids and
not showing their faces because
they're supposed to look different
because the parents don't notice yet it
was really interesting it was very well
executed then when the aging starts
getting noticed in the kids who are
like oh you're teenagers now but you're
still mentally five or six years old i
thought that was a great layer on the
performances these actors who were
playing teenagers had to still
play characters who were mentally not
teenagers yet they were five and six i
thought it was strong it was great and i
felt like it kind of
went away at a point because then the
movie's a series of situations and
scenarios that happen that have to do
with the fact that
time is sped up and but we know that
there's no intrigue there we just
we know it's happening it is cool to see
the things that m night shyamalan
thought about how we could apply sped up
time to elements that
speak to horror there are a couple
elements later on in the movie that i
was like that's
it's imaginative it's creepy and i liked
it rufus sewell
is one of the standouts in this movie
because he always is rufus
is always a standout in most anything
he's in he brings kind of an overbearing
uneasy what's going on with this guy
creepy element to the movie which is
ironic because
his character is also a doctor so one of
the more unsettling characters
in this movie is one of the most
advantageous people to have on a beach
like this
a doctor but among the scenarios that
happened to these people on this beach
there's one in particular where i was
like
oh okay i saw it in the trailer so i
want to say spoiler-ish but it's in the
trailer if you know what you're looking
at because in the trailer i was like oh
kids and they start rapidly aging so
they look like teenagers and
uh wait a minute they're not gonna go
there they do i mean it doesn't show it
or anything but they're hanging out in
the tent and they come out and unless
it's the immaculate conception in which
cue the trumpets something happened in
there with two characters who are
physically 14
15 year olds mentally five or six year
olds yeah it's weird
objectively it is logical that that
would happen in that scenario when you
have two kids in a tent and they're
rapidly aging and they go past puberty
and they're like i have all these other
emotions and thoughts and things i want
to do and there are no parents around it
would probably happen that said
how does it serve the movie not at all
you could edit the rapidly aging
pregnancy scenario out of this movie and
it wouldn't affect the movie at all it's
just one of the many things that happens
to these people on this beach i mean
this is not something you remember after
the movie
you'll remember it a little bit like i
remember it because i remember watching
the movie i was like oh great okay so
i have to address this in my video
perfect so i had a different mental
assessment than other people who will
watch this movie that said
i said it and now you know and now my
job is done so on one hand there's an
interesting movie in here about seeing
rapid growth and
the introspective nature of aging and
facing your mortality but it's buried
under these messy m night shyamalan
isms some of which is just cheesy lines
spoken from people you know how
directors have those things where you're
like
you wrote that with m night shyamalan
it's usually someone awkwardly saying
something
at the wrong moment also there's a lot
of exposition in this movie you remember
in gladiator
when maximus was gonna get executed the
guy tried to draw a sword and he
couldn't he was like
frost makes the blade stick because if
maximus hadn't said that
most the audience would be like why
couldn't he unsheath this sword so
sometimes you have to have the
characters
explain things to the audience this
movie does that
all the time right down to these moments
where it's like this on the nose
round table discussion of like what's
going on i think this is going on it's
like
man that's that's not occam's razor you
just you made all these leaps
and i think you're right like you're
definitely not wrong this is the movie
explaining what's going on to us but man
those
leaps doesn't make any sense that you
would know that that could have been
done in a more clever way heck
i didn't even have to know why this was
happening to these people sometimes
horror is horror and you just don't
always get to know why
and there is a point in this movie where
i was like and if the movie had ended
there that would have been fine that
would have been perfect would have saved
some time but you know you got to keep
going and you got to
show more things than you actually need
to show in the end this movie reminded
me of when my dad and i would go to
hollywood video or blockbuster or
something he would stumble across some
weird rando ass movie probably
horror or thriller or something he's
like oh have you seen this movie i'm
like no
not at all kinda never even heard of it
he's like all right i'm not gonna tell
you anything about it but
we gotta watch it this movie is like
that it's one of those movies you know
it's one of those movies you're supposed
to show somebody who knows
nothing about the premise sadly a lot of
us do so that ruins an element of this
movie but if you're a shyamalan superfan
or at least you want to see what's in
the loot box i'd say the movie's still
worth a watch but there's a caveat it's
a fine yet messy thriller no alcohol
required
at matinee price yeah you got to throw
in a caveat here and there why not all
right so old have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you